Anita Kumari, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm doing wonderful.
Thank you for inviting me.
I'm honored to be here.
Well, I'm always excited
to talk about happiness,
and I have a feeling
that we're going to talk about happiness
over the next 20 minutes or so
because you've had a fabulous career
at so many wonderful companies
as a senior human resource, right?
You were at Kaiser and Google
and VeriFone,
and different other companies
that we won't go into detail here.
But then you've transitioned
into happiness and mental health,
and you've written a book
"Find Your Happy"
which you've just shown me a second ago.
Maybe you can show it again
in a second. Beautiful.
And one of the things you told me
that you're really passionate about
is the space of mental health
and limiting beliefs
and how to go beyond
those limiting beliefs.
So Anita, enough from me,
I want to hear about you a little bit
and about your journey.
Yeah. So, I used to be
in a high tech corporate career
throughout my life.
And then life threw me a few curveballs,
and I had to learn
how to throw aces and not give in.
And that was a point in my life
when I started going
into emotional development
and self growth
and started doing courses
like Landmark, Tony Robbins, Oprah,
Deepak Chopra.
... meditation
and yoga and all that stuff.
And because
when I was going through stuff,
I was in a very abusive relationship
at that point in my time.
And because of my cultural background,
I wasn't willing to leave
even though everyone around me
was telling me to leave.
Like every weekend,
like other people used to say,
"Oh Friday, everyone is happy
that they have a weekend.
Why are you so scared?"
But I was scared to be
alone at home with him, right,
because I didn't know
what was going to happen
because he had already tried
to kill me three times.
Whoa whoa whoa whoa. Okay.
I'm sorry, Anita, before we move on,
I'd love to hear a little bit more
because, obviously,
the second part of this journey
is going to be a wonderful one
about how you're empowering
other women now
and you're inspiring other women.
But as long as you feel comfortable,
I'd love to understand a little bit more
about what happened there
and how you broke free of that.
Sure. So, let me give you
a little bit of background
of how I even ended up with him.
So, because I'm from India
and I've grown up in a very sheltered
and nice family atmosphere. So, basically
if someone will say something,
I would trust them, right?
And I met this guy who was my friend,
and I was very young
and he told me he will kill himself
if I don't marry him.
And now I know that's crazy,
but that time I thought he loved me
that's why.
And I thought,
Anyway, I have to ...
why not marry him
because he loves me so much.
So, I got married pretty young
and came here.
And then I did my MBA.
Where is this in the world by the way?
Oh this, I met him in India,
but we came here
as soon as we decided to get married
because my parents wouldn't approve,
his parents wouldn't approve.
We were very young.
Wow.
Yeah. And I finished only
my undergrad at that time.
And I came here
and I think for one year
the fairytale lasted,
but after that, I ... job.
I started getting very successful.
And even from my first job,
I don't know why people
started putting me with the VPs and stuff
even though I was like scared
that I was like a very junior person.
But someone, they saw leadership qualities,
and so every time I would have a meeting,
he would try to sabotage it.
I started doing MBA
and got into Dean's scholar list.
And that was like every time
something like that would happen,
that ...
he would get more abusive.
And so, when you say abusive,
just to clarify,
that is obviously the emotional abuse ...
And the physical abuse ...
But every time I,
once or twice I had gotten mad
that I'll go and tell someone
and then he would start crying
and then I would feel sorry for him
so I wouldn't usually tell someone.
But what happened is
I'm a very happy person.
I started totally losing myself
in the sense I wouldn't even smile.
And people who knew us
like from our ...
they used to say,
"What did you do to her?
She doesn't even smile anymore.
She used to laugh so much."
But anyway, I didn't think any of it.
I just thought if I ... myself more
because he didn't like me doing anything
which got me any recognition.
So I stopped writing poetry,
I stopped being on stage,
I stopped pretty much
talking to people,
and I got so under-confident
that if someone would so much
as say hello to me
I would start crying, right.
And I wouldn't ...
I wouldn't even like
go to a grocery store alone,
and the people who know me then
they say that I always used to walk
with my head down.
But I didn't realize
because I was the one doing it, right?
And I used to think of it it's my fault,
like if I do this different,
that different, he might change.
But nothing changed.
And then, because I used to go
to my doctor for everything he did,
she referred me to a therapist
who told me I should leave
while I still can in one piece.
Wow. That's what she said?
She said you should leave
while you still can in one piece.
Yes. Because she said
with his demeanor, he can even break
your hands and legs
if you tell him you will leave
and then pretend to take care of you.
So, but I didn't understand that time.
So, that was my foray
into mental health
because, so I mean,
finally I had a miscarriage
because of him.
And I even was scared
if I go into, I was hiking
in the Santa Cruz Mountains,
and he took me to a very deserted place
where there was no one.
And on top of the hill,
he was like getting one of his moods
and I was thinking,
if he pushes me right now
no one will ever know
what happened to me, right?
And that was my,
I think, wake up call little bit.
And another was miscarriage.
And then I just decided to leave
and I just left with a few clothes
and few shoes.
But after I left,
and I took a restraining order,
but he was able
to emotionally manipulate me
to feel guilty of leaving him
and made me sign a power of attorney.
Pretty much he kept everything.
So anyway, so I started my life
from ground zero.
So, just for context,
your starting your life again
at ground zero. First of all,
I can't even believe what I'm hearing.
And so, I'm extremely inspired
by the next thing
that we're gonna talk about
because you took that adversity
and you're channeling that through
to empower other women
and other people around the world.
But before that, give me the context.
So, when you leave with a bag of clothes
and some shoes, how old are you?
Where are you in the US?
What are you doing during that time?
Yes, I was out of a job at that time
so I didn't want to leave,
but it was so bad
that I could not stay.
And so, I had a friend who said,
"Okay, you can."
My therapist also told me,
"Don't live alone
because he's going to come after you."
So, I had a friend, so I decided to,
they said that I can stay
in their house for a little bit.
So, I just picked up some clothes.
I decided to, I went with them
and started living there.
And didn't tell anyone where I was
because otherwise he would come
and he was trying to get me back.
But my therapist told me,
"Don't go back
because you won't be alive then
'cause now he knows
that you can leave" right.
Because any time I would say,
"I will leave."
when he was misbehaving or abusing,
then he would say,
"If you try to leave,
I'll kill you and kill myself."
So, I thought it was that way.
But the thing is,
I mean, if you have heard
of severe narcissistic, psychotic person,
I think he was one of that.
So he knew ... how he can manipulate me
because he knew me from my childhood.
I had no support system here.
And because I was only allowed
to be friends
with his friends' wives kind of thing.
So, but still, I had some colleagues
and some people who I think
God sent to help me.
And then I joined a job
within, I think, a few weeks of moving out.
And so I started saving money
and meanwhile, I know in California,
it's community property.
I even like, my therapist
had referred me an attorney
and I thought I'll hire him,
but he found out and he convinced me
that attorneys take all the money
so I should not have any attorney.
So, I didn't have any attorney,
and he had two in the background.
And so basically,
he was able to threaten me
to ... make me feel guilty enough
for me to give him
the power of attorney.
I have to ask,
the parents back home in India,
your community back home in India,
are they a part of the picture
at this point?
Are they involved in any way?
No, they are not,
because my family is very simple.
Like if you tell them
he did this, they'll say,
"Oh, let us talk to him.
He will get better" right.
Because they don't know anyone
can be that bad, that psychotic.
And they are too far away.
I have to say, so I understand that mindset,
but I have to, because
in the last few months,
I've been hearing constantly about,
there are so many stories
that have come up of domestic abuse
and domestic violence, not just in the US,
but around the world,
that hearing it firsthand now
from your experience,
it just brings up all these emotions
of reading all these articles.
So, I can't even imagine
what it's like going through that.
You know, it was really bad.
Believe me, I didn't even know
I will survive that year
because I'd never lived alone
in my life,
I was in a foreign country
with no support system, no money,
and even after I moved out
of that friend's place,
as soon as I found a job, right.
So, I had no furniture.
I slept on the floor
'til I was able to buy my furniture.
And I had a friend who gave me one glass,
one ... one plate, some like,
because I cook a lot at home.
So some rice, some lentil, everything.
So, she was like an angel for me
even though I didn't know her that well.
But she realized it, right,
because she's an older woman.
And so I took me,
I think a month or something or more,
to get the furniture, buy something,
then gradually buy my utensils.
Now I have everything,
and I'm proud to say it's all my-made
and doesn't belong to anyone else.
100% my hard work.
And during this course
I kept on doing
all the self development
because it takes a long time to heal.
So, I wasn't willing to go
into any relationship.
I wasn't willing to date anyone.
I wasn't willing to trust any guy
because I wasn't healed.
Right
So, I'm glad that
I went through all this trainings
to really heal, and not just really heal,
my therapist then started
trying to put me on an antidepressant.
And I know the side effects.
So, I decided I'm not going to take it.
I'll start every day with meditation,
yoga, and some zumba class or kickboxing,
something which is very
untoward of the person I was ...
So, that gradually got me out
of my comfort zone.
And in order for me
to really be able to even trust
or be like next to a guy again,
because,
when you are really hurt,
you basically you think
everyone is the same, right?
Even though it's a small sample,
one person.
So, I started taking salsa lessons
where you have to dance with a guy, right,
a partner.
Yeah. I love salsa.
Yeah. Thank you. Me too.
And dancing is very good.
I think that was also,
so that gradually got me out of that,
I would say, out of that fear,
I mean, apart from my self development.
And then I realized
so many of my friends,
even if like real things like this
are happening,
sometimes they are not able
to get out of it
and sometimes they don't talk about it
or they feel ashamed
like I used to feel ashamed before.
Now I empower with this story.
And also I used to, I wouldn't even dare
to dress up or things like that
because always he would be
very, very crazy about it, right.
I'm sure.
Yeah. So, right now I feel that
all mental issues can be resolved
with natural mental exercises
or hypnotherapy and psychology
and without medication too.
I mean of course,
some people who are totally extreme,
then they need the medication
at that time,
but most of the things like anxiety,
stress, worry, panic attacks, OCD,
moodiness, and not feeling enough
not feeling love,
those things are self-esteem.
They all can be resolved.
And like I have resolved
and you see ... living example
from where, if you see my pictures there,
I look like 15 years older
than I look right now.
Wow. Yeah.
So, I'd love to talk
about that transition,
because now, you are doing
such wonderful things
with a new startup, HappinessFactor,
and I'll say it now and later,
but you have also
opened positions for interns
that I'd love to tell a lot of my friends
about it because it sounds
like a wonderful opportunity.
But you also wrote the book,
"Find Your Happy"
Talk to me about this journey
in writing this book
and what led to that.
Yeah. So, people knew me
as a high tech ... person
because that was my background.
So I ... and wanted them to think of me
as a happiness
and emotional wellness expert.
And then people told me
"Oh, it will take one year to write a book"
I didn't have one year
because I wanted to create the branding.
I said, "I'll write it in one month"
and everyone laughed at me.
But when I'm dedicated,
I'm really dedicated.
For one month, I slept for four hours.
I found 10 or 20 people to interview,
because I only wanted to write
about real life stories.
So, I interviewed someone
who had killed someone with six bullets,
was incarcerated for life,
but how meditation changed his life
and now he's out, he has a wife and a kid.
Then I interviewed someone now
who had survived breast cancer
and she's also thriving.
She's a good friend of mine.
Then someone who had gone through
debilitating accidents,
or very bad divorces,
so much so like I have a friend
who lost everything in the divorce
and still is fighting custody for his kid.
And then people who have gone through abuse,
people who have gone through, of course,
the abuse has some part of my story too,
though he doesn't have my name.
And then someone who was raped
when he was eight years old
and he never told anyone,
and finally I covered his story.
And now they found out that the same guy
under the pretext
of helping those young kids
because they were from a very poor family,
very big family,
like 17, 18 brothers, sisters,
parents didn't have enough to feed
in Chicago.
And that guy used to tell the parents
that I will give this kid some work
to stack shoeboxes
because he had a shoe shop,
and he used to rape them behind.
... didn't know they were raped.
And so, this actually story
has given me the maximum kudos
because many people write to me
that reading that,
they don't feel ashamed
and they got closure.
Because people feel ashamed, right,
even if it's not their fault.
That's what I think the perpetrators
always take advantage of.
When you are too gullible
and too innocent,
and you believe everything they say,
especially if you don't have
a support system or if you don't know
what's going on.
So, all the 10 stories in my book
are real stories of real life people.
And at the end of each chapter
I have given how they have overcome
and are thriving in life,
so why can't you
who have so much going on.
Because many times when I quote people,
one on one they say,
"Oh, it's easy for you to say
because you never had anything bad."
They don't know my background, right?
So, they think right now
I look happy, so I must have everything
going so good for me all the time.
And so, then I wanted them to see that
no, not everyone has it going good
all the time;
the people who are really successful
are the ones who make the best
of what's happening and come out,
learn enough from that experience
and come out of ...
Unbelievable. Wow.
Okay, that's truly inspiring.
And again, a lot of people can talk about
mental wellness and happiness.
A lot of these people are coming
from solid backgrounds,
from okay upbringings,
but the adversity that you went through
and the emotional strifes
that you went through,
I think it's just inspiring
that you're channeling that
towards helping others.
And so, in the last few minutes
that we have, I'd love to learn
about the HappinessFactor
and what you are doing with that startup,
because you decided to leave
the traditional tech world
and the positions
that you've held before
with human resources
and now you've transitioned
into this startup.
So, talk to me about that.
Yeah. So, I started my startup,
HappinessFactors, three years ago.
At that time when I started,
even though I have some very good mentors,
like some of my ex VPs joined,
some of the very famous
Fortune 500 people are on my board,
as well as quite a few doctors
and LP practitioners and hypnotherapists.
And so, initially when I started,
I had a few mentors and they told me
"Who will pay for happiness?"
People think happiness ... come free.
And now everyone tells me,
"You are in the right place, right time."
...
So, I think I saw it
much before others did, right?
So that time I started,
and then I wanted to develop an app
that time when I started.
But still, I did my research on Headspace,
on Calm, and all others available.
And I found what's not working
because many of my friends,
the companies buy those apps for them
but they don't use it
because they don't find it
interesting enough.
So, I decided to do
a different way.
So, I made it more gamified
and more interesting
and more targeted
towards the millennials.
And I made sure that all the background
is very happy and people can relate to it.
And so, right now
it's still getting developed,
and the app is just a very small part.
So, I'm doing the whole ecosystem.
So, we have coaches on site
where we coach people on anxiety,
on whatever problem
they come up with
because first session is always free.
That's called a strategy session
where we decide
if it's a good fit for us or them or not.
If not, I'll refer them to someone else.
If it's a good fit,
then we will take it
on HappinessFactors
and either it will be me or someone else
who will be coaching them.
We also do lots of keynotes
at different companies.
Actually, I did one on mental health
at ServiceNow just two days ago
which went pretty well.
And I'm sure I'll be called back
to do another bigger session
because many people
were talking about that.
Then I do lots of workshops and trainings.
Right now, everything is of course,
on Zoom,
but I love to do in person,
and I have done like ... from one day
to halfday, to two days
at different companies
and mostly high tech
because that's my background.
But mental health
is universally applicable.
It doesn't have to be limited
to high tech.
And I also did some talks for some high schools
and some colleges here too.
And I got called to do one
at the Cupertino High,
but it got postponed
because of covid again.
And they were saying
that mental health is so important
for these teenagers
who are working so hard
to get into a good schoo,
and the stress sometimes gets to them,
right.
So, how to manage that and not get angry.
So, we are creating
a whole emotional wellness ecosystem,
a one stop shop for everything
emotional wellness,
and we are doing it
without the use of drugs,
alcohol, or marijuana.
So that's my tagline,
that we not just help you
get happiness,
but sustain it without drugs,
alcohol, or marijuana.
And we are combining
the eastern methodologies
of Ayurveda, Yoga, Vedic teachings,
Sanatana Dharma,
and with Western psychology,
hypnotherapy,
neuro-linguistic programming, MER,
energy healing,
and creating unique solutions
that's not just take care of the symptoms
of mental health issues,
but they get rid of the root cause
so that people can live
a happy and fulfilled life
for as long as they want.
Anita, thank you for this.
Thank you for the wonderful work
that you're doing
and for helping others around the world.
Before we leave, I want to thank you
for being so generous
with your time as well.
And I'd love to hear three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
I would say unstoppable,
resilient, confident.
[crosstalk]
... tiny beam of light.
I love that. I love that.
Thank you very, very much.
Thank you.
Stay safe and stay healthy,
and I look forward
to maintaining in touch.
Thank you for everything.
Thank you so much.
Have a great evening.
You too.